nous sommes au milieu des années 1970
Michel Welbeck est élève à l'agro la
grande école française de l'agronomie la
science de l'agriculture les élèves
doivent faire un stage de 3 mois dans
une ferme puis remettre un rapport de
stage celui de Welbeck reçoit les éloges
de ses professeurs il reçoit la lettre A
la plus haute dans l'échelle de notation
l'examinateur admire son sens aigu de
l'observation et son expérience du
terrain le jeune Welbeck ne s'attendait
pas à ça pourquoi parce qu'il est parti
de la ferme au bout de seulement 2
jours
Michel Welbeck est l'écrivain français
contemporain le plus lu dans le monde
mais aujourd'hui il n'est plus vraiment
un écrivain il est une marque une icône
culturelle française et pourtant il est
loin de faire l'unanimité ses
provocations lui ont aliéné une bonne
partie de l'opinion publique d'un côté
il donne l'impression d'être comme les
protagonistes de ses premiers romans une
victime sincère de la société mais
certains à commencé par son biographe
Denis de montpion estiment que wbeck est
un manipulateur super intellig vous
allez voir qu'il y a un peu des deux je
vais vous raconter 10 anecdotes
révélatrices pour comprendre qui est
vraiment Welbeck il y en a trois quatre
qui sont surprenantes et aussi il faut
le dire
[Musique]
dérangeante nous sommes au milieu de
l'année 1956 le petit Michel est né il y
a seulement 5 mois le contrat de travail
de sa mère est fini les parents de
Michel en profitent pour faire un voyage
de 6 mois en Afrique ils laissent leur
bébés chez sa grand-mère paternelle
Welbeck a donc un enfant quasi abandonné
par ses parents il ressent un cruel
manque affectif toute sa vie et peut
également ressentir ce manque affectif
chez les protagonistes de ces romans
Welbeck entre donc dans la vie avec un
handicap affectif au tout début déjà les
parents abandonnent leur nourrion pour
partir à l'aventure moi qui ai eu la
chance de recevoir beaucoup d'attention
et d'amour de mes deux parents cela me
choque je ne sais pas ce que vous en
penseer vous pouvez me le dire dans les
commentaires et les parents de Welbeck
ne changent pas à leur retour ils se
séparent rapidement alors le père qui
est un alpiniste chevrené voyage dans le
monde entier la mère s'installe comme
médecin généraliste à la Réunion et elle
estime que sa quantité de travail ne lui
permet pas d'élever son fils dans de
bonnes conditions le petit Michel
grandit donc sans ses parents et ça ça
explique en partie sa critique notamment
dans les particules élémentaires de la
contreculture libertaire des années 60
dans laquelle ont baigné ses deux
parents ils sont tous les deux
intelligents cultivés et épris de
liberté mais ils aiment tellement la
liberté qu'ils y sacrifient leurs
responsabilité et ce sont les autres qui
en font les frais à commencé par leur
fils la mère de Welbeck abandonnera
également son second
enfant le père de Michel s'appelle René
th sa mère s'appelle Janine sealdi donc
l'écrivain s'appelle officiellement
Michel Thomas alors où est-ce qu'il a
trouvé le nom Welbeck et pourquoi avoir
choisi ce nom et bien c'est le nom de
jeune fille de sa grand-mère paternelle
celle qui s'est occupé de lui quand ses
parents l'ont abandonné à 5 mois
Henriette Welbeck est la personne qui a
le plus compé dans sa vie c'est pour ça
qu'il a choisi ce nom c'est elle qui lui
a donné sa dose d'amour originelle elle
ne s'est pas contenté de garder son
Petitfils elle l'a choyé et gâté sans
réserve et chez les humains comme chez
les animaux l'adulte reste profondément
attaché au protecteur dont il a reçu des
soins quand il était enfant lui qui est
si sarcastique Welbeck n'a jamais amis
la moindre critique envers sa grand-mère
paternelle il a également reçu de
l'amour de ses autres grands-parents ses
grands-parents maternels chez lesquels
ses parents l'ont laissé après leur
séparation nous sommes en 1975 Welbeck a
19 ans après 2 ans en classe prépa bio
au lycée Chaptal à Paris il a passé les
écrits des concours des grandes écoles
les plus réputé résultat il est
admissible partout y compris à la la
très prestigieuse École Normale
Supérieure il finit même 9e des écrits
du concours de normals mais il y a un
truc qui le dérange aucun de ses copains
n'y est admissible il n'a pas envie de
perdre ses amis de prépa donc il sèche
l'oral de normalsu cette anecdote révèle
que Welbeck est un surdoué sans ambition
enfin jusqu'à ce qu'il trouve sa voie
son aisance intellectuelle c'est d'abord
une affaire de gêne le père de Welbeck a
quitté l'école à 13 ans mais il a une
vive intelligence qui lui vaut le
respect de ses amis la mère de Welbeck
est clairement une surdouée en plus de
son militantisme communiste ce qui lui
donne une bonne culture politique en
plus de son engagement elle fait
médecine et elle termine major de promo
elle a également une grande culture
littéraire elle est capable de réciter
par cœur des passages entiers de
dostoyevski pas étonnant avec de tels
parents que Welbeck soit doué mais c'est
l'attention de ses grands-parents
maternels et qui permet de développer
son potentiel sa précocité les éblouis à
3 ans il sait lire et à 4 ans il écrit
des mots compliqués sans faire aucune
faute à l'école au collège au lycée en
prépa il aura moins d'efforts à fournir
que les autres un surdoué mental un
sous-doué affectif dit sa mère
avec sa voix grave sculptée par le tabac
Philippe ségin a été le plus
charismatique président de l'Assemblée
nationale où siègeent les députés de la
République française il exerce cette
fonction de 1993 à 1997 un jour Philippe
sin a un problème avec son ordinateur il
contacte donc le service d'assistance
buretique de l'assemblée il a affaire à
un homme bizarre lent qui semble être
dans un autre monde comme le président
de l'Assemblée a du mal à faire
confiance à ce dépanneur il insiste il
le secoue verbalement ce dépanneur n'est
donc pas fan de s gin qu'il appelle le
gros très chiant vous l'avez compris le
dépanneur c'est Michel wbeck au début
des années 1990 il travaille au service
informatique de l'Assemblée nationale
dans les années 1980 il avait travaillé
dans une société de service en
informatique avant d'être contractuel
pour le ministère de l'Agriculture cette
anecdote révèle que Welbeck a
l'expérience du monde du travail moderne
contrairement à beaucoup d'auteurs et
d'artistes qui critiquent la société
depuis l'extérieur Welbeck lui a eu un
quotidien professionnel qui ressemble à
celui de beaucoup de gens la France
étant une économie ie de service pour le
dire simplement il a été un Français
moyen sur le plan professionnel dans la
vingtaine et la trentaine il occupe des
emplois purement alimentaires comme
beaucoup de Français son travail ne
l'intéresse pas mais il n'a pas le choix
ses finances sont fragiles et il a un
enfant à charge et contrairement à ce
que sa bizarrerie laisse imaginer il est
un employé fiable il est à l'heure il ne
crée pas de problème il fait ce qu'on
lui demande et même de manière
intelligente il est intégré et apprécié
là où il travaille surtout il observe en
agronome le milieu où il évolue son
expérience du monde du travail lui
permettra de retranscrire ire l'ambiance
bureaucratique déprimante qui est celle
de beaucoup de grandes entreprises et
d'administration au début des années
1990 toutes les éditions refusent
extension du domaine de la lutte le
premier roman de Welbeck or beaucoup de
gens moi compris pensent aujourd'hui que
c'est le meilleur enfin c'est facile
après coup d'accuser les éditeurs de ne
pas avoir eu de flair à l'époque Welbeck
bénéficie pourtant du soutien de
Dominique Noguez un critique littéraire
qui a ses entrées dans le monde de
l'édition c'est lui qui pousse pour
faire publier extension du domaine de la
lutte en vain mais Welbeck bénéficie
d'un soutien encore plus puissant celui
de la femme qu'il aime et cette femme a
une position encore plus utile que celle
du critique littéraire Dominique nogz
elle est la secrétaire de la maison
d'édition la différence qui a publié le
premier recueil de poésie de Welbeck
autrement dit elle est une Insider dans
le milieu de l'édition elle harcèle
littéralement Maurice nado le patron des
éditions du même nom et un jour il
accepte de publier extension du domaine
de la lutte cette anecdote montre que
Welbeck n'est pas un génie sorti de
nulle part à la sortie de son premier
roman il est déjà un initié du monde
littéraire parisien il est entré dans ce
microcosme par la poésie dès ses études
d'agronomie il participe à des soirées
où se retrouvve des amoureux de poésie
ce genre malaimé une fois dans la vie
active il continue de relation en
relation il se rapproche des éditeurs de
poésie il publie d'abord ses poèmes dans
des revues puis un recueil la poursuite
du bonheur paraît en 1991 on ne publie
pas un recueil de poème pour gagner de
l'argent et pourtant la maison d'édition
doit rapidement réimprimer un nouveau
stock d'exemplaire les ventes ont
dépassé ses espérances Welbeck obtient
même en 1992 le Prix Tristan Sara du nom
du poète du début du 20e siècle qui a
fondé le dadaisme ce premier succès lui
permet de pénétrer un peu plus le
microcosme littéraire parisien il se
rapproche par exemple de Jean
edernaliier le polémiste le plus en vue
des années mitéran le talent de welbec
est de plus en plus reconnu jusqu'au
succès inattendu d'extension du domaine
de la lutte pardon pourinterruption mais
j'ai une question à vous poser vous
croyez vraiment que les gens ont lu tous
les livres dont il parlent bien sûr que
non sinon on ne pourrait pas parler de
grand-chose et oui il y a 24 he dans une
journée et il faut travailler manger
dormir et sortir le
chien donc le secret de la culture
générale ce n'est pas de lire des livres
c'est quoi alors en fait il n'y a pas un
seul secret il y en a cinq les étudiants
et les personnes les plus cultivées les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets vous savez vous avez lu
Renant comme moi mais il se garde bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer rapidement et
facilement leur culture générale parce
que leur rapport au savoir a changé et
une fois qu'ils appliquent les cinq
secrets ils comprennent toutes les
références des personnes cultivées ils
savent s'exprimer avec profondeur sur
n'importe quel sujet ils brillent par
leur culture dans les conversations et
dans les débats et ils ont le recul
nécessaire pour faire preuve d'esprit
critique ça vous intéresse et bien je
vous révèle les cinq secrets et je vous
explique comment les appliquer dès
aujourd'hui pour vous cultiver 10 fois
plus rapidement sans vous prendre la
tête pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant en haut à droite de
la vidéo soit sur celui qui est dans la
description de la vidéo c'est l'histoire
de 10 secondes donc faites-le maintenant
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier
secret qui vous attendra bien au chaud
dans votre boîte mail après avoir
regardé cette vidéo voilà voilà je vous
ai dit ce que je voulais vous dire bonne
vidéo nous sommes à l'été 1998 le
directeur du camping l'espace du
possible appelle flamarion il est
foudrage le deuxième roman de Welbeck
les particules élémentaires qui
s'apprête à sortir donne une très
mauvaise image de son établissement il
passe pour un repère de babacou frustré
sexuel Welbeck refuse de changer le nom
du camping le directeur saisit donc la
justice avec une procédure d'urgence il
obtient la destruction de tous les
exemplaires disponibles pour éviter cela
Flam Marion doit modifier le nom du
camping et il faut le faire place pour
place Welbeck a une seule nuit pour
trouver un nouveau nom qui comporte
autant de caractères que l'espace du
possible ce sera le lieu du changement
il y a ensuite une audience les grands
noms du monde littéraire parisien se
succèdent pour demander le rejet des
poursuites au nom de la liberté du
romancier seulement la liberté du
romancier Welbeck la pousse très très
loin cette anecdote illustre un de ses
travers il ne respecte pas dans ses
romans l'anonymat des personnes dont il
s'inspire non seulement il raconte des
scènes réelles peu flatteuses pour les
personnes impliqué mais en plus ils
donnent leur véritable nom c'est du
jamais vu dans la fiction par exemple
dans extension du domaine de la lutte
son premier roman il reproduit très
précisément la nomenclature du ministère
de l'agriculture avec ses directions ses
départements c'est bureau ses
sous-directions et puis il met en scène
d'anciens collègues plus précisément
ceux qu'il n'appréciait pas il en fait
des portraits féroces sans changer leur
identité parmi les victimes qui ont été
mises au courant certaines ont hésité à
porter plainte mais elles ont finalement
renoncé anticipant que cela nuirait
encore plus à leur
anonymat je vous lis un passage des
particules élémentaires c'est à propos
d'un personnage qui veut se reconvertir
dans le rock à l'âge de 26 ans avant de
faire le tour des studios
d'enregistrement il décida d'enlever 2
ans à son son âge c'était très facile à
faire il suffisait au moment où on lui
demandait son âge de répondre 24 ans
naturellement personne ne vérifier si si
il y a des personnes qui vérifient un
biographe rigoureux comme Denis
desmontpion par exemple il a trouvé que
wbeck est né en 1956 ce qui est confirmé
par les actes d'état civil et non en
1958 comme l'écrivain l'a mainte fois
affirmé et Welbeck ne se rajeunit pas
uniquement dans les conversations en
2002 ces propos controversés sur l'Islam
lui valte un procès le mémoire remis au
juge par l'avocat stipule dès les
premières lignes que Welbeck est né en
1958 alors que dans des documents
antérieurs à sa célébrité il dit
lui-même qu'il est né en 1956 pourquoi
aller jusque là pourquoi mentir sur un
détail d'un côté dans ses romans
c'est-à-dire dans la fiction il met en
scène sous leur vrai nom de vraies
personnes qui n'ont rien demandé de
l'autre côté dans la réalité dans des
documents à valeur juridique il change
son année de naissance et puis certaines
personnes qui le fréquentent le
soupçonneent de raconter des histoires
inventées en fait comme beaucoup de
romanciers Welbeck prend plaisir à
brouiller les pistes entre la réalité et
la fiction a mystifié le public mais
Céline ne disait-il pas une biographie
ça
s'invente nous sommes le mardi 11
septembre 2001 Michel Deon un écrivain
français a accueilli Welbeck après une
violente dispute conjugale l'après-midi
les deux hommes discuteent
tranquillement autour d'un verre pendant
ce temps l'épouse de Michel Deon fait
les courses au village et à l'épicerie
elle remarque un attroupement inhabituel
devant le téléviseur les images incroybl
d'avion de ligne fonçant sur les tours
du World Trade Center tournent en boucle
de retour chez elle elle dit à son mari
qu'il faut absolument allumer la
télévision Welbeck et ses autes restent
boucheb devant l'écran à un moment
Michel Deon lui dit vous êtes sauvé
pourquoi est-ce qu'il lui dit ça parce
que Welbeck s'est mis à dos une partie
de l'opinion publique en critiquant et
on peut même plutôt dire en insultant
l'islam la provocation qui lui a causé
le plus de souci c'est lorsqu'il a dit
en 2001 dans une interview du magazine
Lire la religion la plus con c'est quand
même l'islam cependant la phrase n'a pas
que des effets négatifs comme le
scandale atteint des sommets les ventes
s'envolent plateforme le 3oisème roman
de Welbeck se vend à 200000 exemplaires
en 12 jours 200000 exemplaires en 12
jours ce que révèle cette anecdote c'est
que la controverse y est pour beaucoup
dans le succès de wbec la formule est
simple les propos qui heurtent la morale
sociale captent l'attention comme les
médias vivent de l'attention du public
il relaie les propos controversés tenus
dans le cadre de la sortie du livre
Welbeck bénéficie donc d'une énorme
publicité et comme les gens s'attendent
à découvrir d'autres propos controversés
dans le roman il l'achète et il y en a
Welbeck parle crument de sexe dénigre
les femmes et l'islam bien sûr on ne
peut pas résumer ses romans à cela mais
ce serait-il aussi bien vendu sans
parfum de
scandale fin 2022 un vidéaste
néerlandais propose à Welbeck de filmer
ses ébats à 3 lui sa femme et une jeune
Hollandaise prétendument étudiante en
philo et fan de sa plume Welbeck accepte
il y a deux tournages l'un à Paris
l'autre à Amsterdam mais voilà lors de
la diffusion de la bande annonce début
2023 Welbeck s'oppose finalement à la
sortie du film ce n'est pas ce qui était
prévu il aurait été négligeent en
signant le contrat bien sûr l'histoire
est relayée par tous les médias Welbeck
revient sur le devant de la scène il se
justifie dans un récit confession qui
sort en mai 2023 quelques mois dans ma
vie cette anecdote illustre le fait que
la sexualité est un ingrédient essentiel
de l'identité artistique de Welbeck dans
ses livre comme dans sa vie personnelle
certes ça n'est plus un tabou comme
celle était il y a un siècle mais la
sexualité est toujours avec la violence
le signal le plus puissant pour capter
l'attention de l'être humain à un niveau
superficiel Welbeck parle beaucoup de
sexe dans ses romans il décrit les
désirs de de ses personnages ainsi que
leurs ébas en terme cru il évoque
l'échangisme qu'il pratique lui-même
mais ses romans transmettent également
un message profond ils ont un thème
majeur qui fait de Welbeck le sociologue
de l'époque la misère sexuelle
occidentale il révèle une prétendue
vérité dérangeante les hommes souffrent
d'avoir une vie sexuelle très limitée si
ce n'est inexistante à cet égard il est
un peu le précurseur du mouvement red
pill en référence à la célèbre scène du
film Matrix mouvement selon lequel la
société occidentale contemporaine est
responsable de la misère sexuelle des
hommes
nous sommes à la toute fin de l'année
2010 Bruno Lemer le ministre de
l'Agriculture contacte l'ambassade de
France en Irlande il demande qu'on
réduise les obligations sanitaires pour
rapatrier la dépouille d'un chien en
France un avion est spécialement
affraité pour l'animal au frais de la
République et donc du contribuable ce
chien c'est Clément le fidèle compagnon
de wbeck et il est bien plus qu'un chien
pour lui les proches de l'écrivain
disent que Clément était sa seule
famille son seul point fixe dans
l'existence Welbeck est toujours avec
Clément il dort même avec le quadrupède
quand il est menacé après ses propos sur
l'islam il confie Clément à des
personnes de confiance afin que l'animal
soit en sécurité cette anecdote révèle
la misanthropie de Welbeck comme
Schopenhauer qui aa influencé et qui
avait également un chien auquel il
tenait beaucoup comme chopenhauer
Welbeck a une vision sombre de
l'humanité il trouvait chez Clément ce
qu'il ne trouvait pas chez ses
semblables la pureté et la fidélité dans
l'affection des années après le décès de
l'animal le Palais de Tokyo le musée le
plus branché de Paris permet à Welbeck
de créer sa propre exposition pour 2
mois il fait de Clément la mascotte du
programme des expositions il lui lui
consacre une amphilade de salle baptisée
amour absolu les spectateurs peuvent y
découvrir un diaporama de l'animal une
statue ainsi que tous ces jouet et
peluches dans des
vitrines si vous aimez l'esprit de cette
vidéo à savoir découvrir des choses
intéressantes en allant à l'essentiel et
sans se prendre la tête alors vous
aimerez probablement mon programme
Culture Express c'est un programme
méthodique pour devenir facilement une
personne cultivée en seulement quelques
mois il couvre tous les domaines de la
culture générale vous maîtriserez des
connaissances essentielles sur
l'histoire de l'humanité sur l'histoire
de France en économie en science
politique en psychologie en sciences en
littérature en art en religion et en
philosophie vous ne saerez plus jamais à
cours de choses à dire et vous gagnerez
la confiance nécessaire pour briller en
toutes circonstances vous pouvez en
savoir plus en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche en haut à droite ou bien sur
celui qui est dans la description ou
bien encore en tapant directement
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran dans
la barre de recherche mais je pense que
la meilleure façon de vous donner une
idée du programme est d'écouter ce que
les membres ont à en dire Valentine qui
reconnaît l'énorme quantité de travail
que ce programme a représenté pour moi
dit je cite que c'est une véritable mine
d'or l'essentiel est là tout est simple
pratique très bien expliqué concentré il
n'y a plus qu'à recopier et à apprendre
ce travail est vraiment formidable et
passionnant Maxens m'écrit directement
dans les commentaires en dessous d'une
vidéo du programme ta formation est
vraiment remarquable j'étais un peu
dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas c'est un vrai
travail de synthèse que tu nous proposes
et le format vidéo est très adapté pour
moi qui est une mémoire essentiellement
auditive le choix des thèmes et des
chapitres est per sinon et je trouve que
tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite à la fois précis mais sans
fioriture vincent lui fait carrément ma
pub j'ai d'ailleurs recommandé votre
formation à ma sœur qui travaille comme
diplomate la semaine dernière elle a
déjà eu l'occasion de mettre à profit
dans ses discussions les connaissances
que vous avez diffusé vous verrez
d'autres témoignage comme ceci dans les
commentaires si vous rejoignez le
programme et si vous vous inscrivez vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultat une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme
je vous rembourserai intégralement si
vous estimez que vous n'avez pas acquis
une solide culture générale si vous
voulez savoir plus cliquez sur le lien
qui s'affiche en haut à droite ou bien
sur celui qui est dans la description ou
bien encore taper directement l'adresse
qui s'affiche à l'écran dans la barre de
recherche plus de 800 membres ont déjà
tiré parti de ce programme et je seraai
ravi qu'il en soit de même pour vous
dans tous les cas j'espère que la vidéo
vous a plu je suis romain et vous vous
étiez sur 1idé de culture générale
rappelez-vous vous n'avez pas besoin de
vous prendre la tête pour vous
intéresser au meilleur de la
[Musique]
pensée